[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with the
financial times is political
correspondent Jasmine Cameron shaleshi
and the columnist for the article Ali
Mirage great to see both of you so to
the front pages then let's start with
the financial times uh Jasmine and her
colleagues at the Ft reporting that the
health secretary Steve Barkley is to
meet ambulance unions tomorrow to
discuss how they will handle cover
during their strike the guardian has
spoken to NHS officials who have warned
that the industrial action could cost
lives
according to the sun would-be ambulance
users are being advised to take taxis
instead
tomorrow's strike by nurses is the top
story for the express which says there
are calls for the prime minister to get
personally involved in Pay negotiations
but in an interview with the Daily Mail
Rishi sunat describes thrall College of
nursing's pay demands as unreasonable
the resulting disruption from both
strikes and the pleas to call them off
are the main focus for the Daily
Telegraph
the Metro has word of a contentious
exchange between Mr Barclay and Sarah
Pennington old whose three-year-old
daughter is currently in hospital being
treated for Cystic Fibrosis over how she
feels the government's Health policies
are putting her child at risk that is
also the lead story for the Daily Mirror
you are working nurses to the Bone their
headline there
and meantime the star has word of
broadcaster Jeremy Clarkson expressing
his regret after a column he wrote for
the son about Meghan Markle was branded
misogynist
we're reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
but let's bring in our guests then we
are joined by Jasmine Cameron schleshy
and Ali Mirage welcome to both of you
um and Jasmine let's go straight to your
paper uh your byline in fact about the
impact of both the nurses strike on
Tuesday and the ambulance staff on at
the strike on on Wednesday with this
meeting with Steve Barkley and some of
the unions tomorrow
yeah so we know that there are a host of
strikes going on this week so we've got
the postal strike there are also rail
strikes but it's really what's happening
in the Health Service that is causing
the most consternation among ministers
so Health secretary Steve Barclay is due
to meet with some of the ambulance
unions tomorrow that includes GMB unite
Unison and they're due to take part in a
strike on Wednesday now there are real
concerns within the government and
within the Health Service about what
impact an ambulance strike will actually
mean on the running of services and it's
quite notable that we've seen that we've
heard from prime minister Rishi sunak as
well as Barclay today who have really
been talking quite tough on this issue
and they've argued that the government
store is always open and they're willing
to discuss various issues with the
health unions um as a company as it
pertains to things like working
conditions but they're not budging on
pay their argument has been that an
independent pay body has set the
recommendations and that was set and
agreed to by the government in I think
it was July of this year and they are
sticking to that now they're putting
forward all these um economic arguments
they're arguing that actually the
government needs to control inflation
they want to take a sensible approach
but ultimately this is turning into a
big political issue for the government
as well but if we look at some of the
polling it shows that actually a lot of
the public are pretty sympathetic to
um individuals who are striking but
particularly those who are striking in
the Health Service and I think I do
Wonder despite the the tough talk by the
government at some point there has to be
some sort of Turning Point especially as
we're hearing all these all these
concerns from Health leaders about what
the impact this week's rights could
actually have well indeed and Ali it is
now is it not about impact mitigation
and indeed advice to members of the
public some suggestions that actually
people should already be told what to do
if we take a look at the the guardian
real suggestions there about the risk to
lives of people dialing 999 we've
already heard that if you're frail or
elderly
um you know one trust suggesting you
could be on the floor for 24 4 to 48
Hours elsewhere the Northwest Ambulance
Service giving a foretaste of the chaos
suggesting that patients have to get
themselves to hospital
unless they have are they were having a
cardiac arrest or facing another threat
to their life mothers to be will have to
do the same unless they are having an
obstetric emergency so you know this is
this is you're out for yourself right
now aren't you with with the ambulance
strikes coming up
it's absolutely dire and this is the
problem that the government has I mean
you you basically as you say you are out
for yourself and if you're like uh my
mother who had two falls in the last few
years I mean if it hadn't been for the
ambulance service we would have been in
big big trouble and that's the problem a
lot of people at the at this time of
year things are cold uh people are on
their own if you fall over and fracture
your hip I mean you could be lying there
for days potentially get hypothermia and
that would be the end I mean it's it's
it's pretty pretty drastic and it is
very very difficult right now uh it
looks like the ambulance service are
only going to come to the most acute
emergencies even heart attacks you're
gonna have to wait up to 90 minutes
potentially to get someone to come and
get you and then once you get to
hospital six out of 10 people in certain
areas are having to wait uh at least an
hour if not longer to get into the
hospital itself and this was a problem
that even began before the strikes uh
took hold that problem of bed blocking
in hospitals caused by shortages in the
care sector both home care and also in
care homes so that you actually have a
basically blocking of beds in hospitals
so people can't actually access them and
people are being backed up in ambulances
outside it's a really really difficult
situation I think there are two issues
here in the short term there's the issue
around pay Jasmine's talked about the
government talking tough they're doing
that because they do not want to stake
inflationary pressures they're saying uh
Richardson has been very explicit saying
he does not want a wage price spiral but
then you've also got a medium term issue
which was alluded to by
the the former Health secretary a few
days ago saying that the NHS is
effectively not fit for purpose it's not
going to be fit for purpose given the
massive pressures and demands upon it I
mean if you take one statistic before
the pandemic took hold there were 1300
people waiting longer than a year in
this country full treatment now there
are four hundred thousand it's like
trying to push things down a funnel if
there's not there's only a certain
amount of space you can do and that is
the problem that we're facing so the
medium-term question we've all got to
face up to is what kind of NHS do we
want do we want an insurance-based
system do we want to pay more for some
of our treatment or are we wedded to
this Holy Grail a free at the point of
use and if so we're gonna all have to
pay a lot more tax to make it work
better it's just not servicing the needs
and the demands put upon it well that's
a bit of a bigger debate that we can
have right here isn't it you know how we
fund and what we do for the future of
the NHS but uh more immediately um
Jasmine the campaign group GP survival
to which some 9 300 family doctors
belong
um have written to NHS England's chief
executive Amanda Pritchard saying that
um the NHS should already have issued
practical advice to the public on how to
move and transport injured and acutely
unwell patients to emergency departments
that's in the guardian and that's on the
front page of the Sun as well a e call a
taxi you know is there is the government
too busy sounding tough on pay on pay
demands um to actually give out Public
Service messaging to people
I mean the government is really
conscious of its messaging at the moment
and what it is communicating to the
public but I do think you know
regardless of what ministers come out
and say ultimately your your view of the
NHS is shaped by your experience of it
if you you know if you're an elderly
individual and you have a fall and you
can't get adequate help if you're a
pregnant mom and you need to get certain
care and you can't or there's a
perception that you can't ultimately
that all of that does matter and I do
think there isn't there is an element of
you know at some point there will have
to be a Breaking Point as Ali noted even
prior to the the strikes there was
already a sense that the NHS was under a
lot of strain we know that there were
Rising flu cases covert still you know
still a big factor that's impacting
um hospitals we know that there were
concerns about delays in terms of
transferring individuals who had arrived
in ambulances two actual enemies there's
a whole host of issues that are
underlying all of these strikes and I do
think what is important to note as well
that the NHS is actually running a
service with you know thousands of
vacancies and I think as part of the the
you know as part of this discussion we
do need to think about you know well
ultimately if it's a stressful and
difficult job people need to be paid
adequately and whether that figure is a
19 pay rise that's for ministers to make
a judgment on but there is an element of
if we want a functioning and healthy
Health Service then you need to have
individuals who feel like they are well
paid well supported and actually you
know this is that comes the heart of the
debate as Ali was saying what type of
service do we want and what type of
worker do we want and how much do we
want to pay them and the Dell Express
says we don't want to break the bank uh
this is the nurses talk to us this is
the leader of the Royal College of
Nursing Pat Cullen making a passionate
plea for the prime minister to intervene
in the dispute for the sake of hundreds
of thousands of nurses who feel totally
abandoned and let down but if we take a
look at the Daily Mail there is an
interview with Rishi sunak suggesting he
will hold out for months now the RCN
today
um Ali suggested their mandate was for
six months I mean could we looking at
nearly six months of strike action here
well look potentially but that'll be
absolutely horrendous I mean look both
sides have to keep these talks going get
around the table I think the health
secretary's been quite clear saying that
there was an independent pay review body
that came up with three to four percent
that was what was uh decided now there's
been some pushback around that saying
that was all decided before we had
rampant inflation uh between 10 and 11
uh you've then got Pat Cullen who I must
say I don't think you're serving her
members particularly well I do have a
lot of Sympathy by the way with nurses
getting a decent pay rise particularly
as we clap for them during covert every
Thursday it's easy to clap much harder
to pay people properly but 19 is not a
serious basis for negotiation and also
playing the low blow card of like saying
that the health sector is not seriously
engaging with nurses because 90 of them
are female is just not realistic and not
an it's a low blow given the fact that
there's strike action writ large across
the public sector and also making claims
that there's trafficking going on of
nurses from certain countries including
Kenya look it that kind of wants to make
a serious charge against that that
should be investigated then that's fine
but I think we need to be sensible on
both sides here I think all the language
needs to be temperate we need to diffuse
this I do think ministers are going to
have to get around the table I don't
think we're going to be able to
indefinitely hide behind this or use
this independent peer review body
indefinitely as as a as an excuse but 19
is not serious there's going to have to
be some sort of deal done okay so that's
betting it at the moment but if he
doesn't want to lead to inflationary pay
Rises across the public sector which I
also understand okay Ali thank you the
19 of course is inflation plus those
years of austerity which held down pay
which we should uh bear in mind too I
guess anyway lots more stuff to come
including what happens when democracy
overrules you it's a problem facing
Donald Trump and Elon musknight
discussing them both next
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview With Me Now Jasmine Cameron
chaleshi and Ali Mirage welcome back to
both of you so Mr Trump um Jasmine uh
yes what will happen to him next this
Congressional committee who's been
looking into the January the sixth
attacks suggest that he should face
criminal charges
yeah so it's quite a dumbing conclusion
they say that he should face full
charges they relate to things such as
obstruction of official proceedings of
inciting or comforting and Insurrection
so it's quite a a striking conclusion
that you know at the end of what's been
quite a tumultuous inquiry into what
happened in on January the 6th of 2021
now I think it's quite interesting when
we step back and put this in the context
of that Donald Trump is trying to
position himself as returning to the
front of Republican politics and I think
this this conclusion is a reminder of
the divisiveness that that his
presidency resulted in and I suspect
there is an element of it doesn't really
change anyone's mind if you were in
favor of trump you see that and think
well you know it was the establishment
against him if you were against Trump
you think well you know this is confirms
what we already knew and so in some ways
it doesn't necessarily move the story
along but it is a helpful example of
actually how you know how impactful
Trump's actions and words were on that
day yes and we'll be very interesting to
see what happens next with that in the
meantime Elon Musk making the front page
of the Ft Ali tell us more
well this is uh Elon Musk actually
putting out a tweet a poll on Twitter uh
asking uh his followers whether he
should actually stand down as CEO of
Twitter and saying that he would abide
by the result now so far
um 57 of those that have actually
bothered to reply to this poll do want
him to stand and you've got to bear in
mind that he's also running SpaceX and
Tesla Tesla's share price has been uh
taking a big hit in recent months on the
back of um his acquisition of Twitter
and he's obviously made a lot of changes
since uh acquiring it for 44 billion
there is someone who apparently has got
a lot of um internet support to step up
which is a Snoop Dogg if he wants to
step away from sipping gin and juice and
take over a CEO of Twitter then he can I
mean I think he'd have a lot of support
for doing that but realistically Elon
Musk is going to have to decide whether
he can find someone to do what he wants
to do I mean at the moment he's already
talked about Twitter potentially going
bankrupt if it's not turned around it's
in financial difficulties he's sacked a
load of people and he's also had loads
of free speech questions to answer as
well in terms of how to balance free
speech with a complete and utter free
for all so not an easy one for him to do
but he is the archetypal CEO so we'll
have to see what he does yeah and he'd
still be the boss even above a CEO
wouldn't he as the owner anyway a quick
Souls from Clarkson Daily Star in just
30 seconds sorry Jasmine
yeah it's quite a striking U-turn so
Clarkson had this um article in the sun
where he expressed in quite Vivid terms
um you know what he'd like to do to Mega
Market it was it was quite a striking
um article there's been a lot of
backlash in terms of whether the
language he used was appropriate and he
seems to sort of had a bit of a mere
culprit and and apologize for some of
the language but I think it does speak
to the fact that Megan and Harry in
their documentary they did talk about
the fact that they felt as though the
the the media
I'm sorry to cut you off run out of time
do apologize Jasmine Ali thank you both
see you later